pour
bonjour à tous bienvenue à ugc
skywest donc la semaine prochaine vous
allez retrouver deux grands films le
premier c'est le nouveau roman polanski
j'accuse du titre éponyme écrit par
emile zola en 1898 emmenés par notamment
aux jean dujardin monsieur emile zola
quelqu'un doit exposer toute l'histoire
en tant qu'officier d'actifs je ne peux
rien écrire là dessus vous non mais
moins si vous vous retrouverez aussi
également le prochain nom 66 avec matt
damon et christian bale qui va retracer
la course mythique du mans en 1966 la
rivalité entre ford et ferrari ont
chassé les deux grandes nouveautés de la
semaine prochaine je vous engage aussi à
les réserver vos places très rapidement
pour la reine des neiges pour tous ceux
qui ont des enfants
naturellement cette date est très
importante le film sort le 20 novembre
prochain
et aussi vous pourrez participer à une
avant première le 6 décembre pour le
film docteur en et par michel blanc et
pour terminer vous avez aussi une grande
un grand film la fin d'une trilogie
très attendu le 18 décembre prochain et
vous pouvez dès maintenant réserver vos
places avec la dernière partie de la
trilogie de star wars
[Musique]